first of all thank you to the jury for a
speedy recovery and I'd like to thank
all those who supported me during his
situation first and foremost I TV
Granada I thank them for their loyalty
and their support all the way through
and I'd have had my management champions
UK without whom this wouldn't have been
possible and in particular John Hayes
who has shown himself to be more so much
more than just a good friend i'd i'd
have had my legal team Louise Blackwell
and Julie Warburton and chart world came
and of course my family who you have
seen I'd like to thank my colleagues and
friends who supported me through this
and all those people that I don't even
know who assembly great support to all
this I'd like to thank games in the
circle of love for their love and energy
that we taught me to this place at this
time and I look forward to being with
them on friday night I just got one
thing to say in these situations there
are no winners and I think we should all
be much kinder to ourselves there now if
you'll excuse me I'd like to get back to
work what I'm guessing what's your
mission for your kids no more thank you